[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando yo digo la palabra feminismo me
preguntó exactamente qué piensan ustedes
qué es eso
me pregunto qué piensa la gente que
tiene la edad de ustedes que es el
feminismo cuando yo digo la palabra
feminista me preguntó exactamente qué es
eso
porque cuando yo tenía la edad yo
ustedes la palabra feminismo la palabra
feminista realmente no significaba nada
muy concreto para mí de hecho era algo
bastante distante era algo bastante
abstracto que
con lo cual yo no me sentía identificada
yo sentía que el feminismo no tenía nada
que ver conmigo y era algo que
pertenecía a un mundo de ideas
y con los años he descubierto que todo
lo contrario el feminismo es muy
concreto
y está muy directamente relacionado con
la vida con la vida de la gente
cuando yo digo la palabra patriarcado me
pasa lo mismo digo patriarcado y pienso
qué pensarán exactamente qué quiere
decir esa palabra qué pensarán ustedes y
qué pensará la gente que tiene la edad
de ustedes cuando yo digo orden
patriarcal o sistema patriarcal qué
piensa la gente qué quiere decir eso
porque cuando yo tenía la edad de
ustedes
patriarcado no era nada para mí no era
ni siquiera una palabra que yo usara o
conociera o reconociera era una idea
distante de mí y que no tenía nada que
ver conmigo
sin embargo con los años he podido ver
que el patriarcado es algo muy concreto
muy específico y muy relacionado con la
vida de todos nosotros y nosotras
el feminismo para mí es una práctica no
es un modelo no es un sistema es rígido
de ideas es una práctica una práctica
que requiere entrenamiento una práctica
que requiere voluntad
el patriarcado por otro lado en palabras
muy sencillas es un sistema que descansa
sobre una idea central es un sistema de
poder es un sistema de relaciones de
poder y descansa sobre una idea central
la idea es ésta lo masculino o los
hombres son superiores a lo femenino o
las mujeres
la mayoría de los hombres que yo conozco
no piensan eso eso es una idea del
patriarcado eso no es necesariamente una
idea de los hombres
pero esas ideas justifican
implementemos en nuestra vida relaciones
en donde como hay una superioridad
asumida
una gente piensa que puede dominar o
ejercer tutela o tutelar o supervisar a
la gente que es inferior quienes
entendemos lo que es el racismo
podemos saber qué cosas justificó el
racismo porque se entendía que un agente
era superior que otra quienes entendemos
lo que es el colonialismo en el mundo y
lo que eso ha hecho en el mundo pues
vemos como los sistemas de creencias si
están insertados en la vida en la vida y
en las relaciones de la gente
el feminismo que yo practico es un
feminismo que cree que es posible
cambiar el mundo y la gente que dice que
es posible cambiar el mundo imagina un
mundo diferente imagina un mundo
concreto no es un mundo abstracto el
mundo que yo imagino que es posible
cambiar es un mundo donde no hay espacio
para lo injusto y donde no hay espacio
para lo desigual y es un mundo en donde
la esperanza está en el centro de
alrededor de la esperanza gira la vida
este es el mundo que yo imagino posible
y lo imagino posible a través de los
poderes que yo le confiere a la práctica
del feminismo
el primer poder que para mí tiene la
práctica del feminismo es el poder de la
inspiración
la inspiración funciona con un efecto de
onda expansiva es una cosa que te toca
y tú no sabes dónde va a terminar el
efecto estoy segura que les ha pasado
alguna vez con alguna idea con alguna
palabra con algún encuentro que de
momento no hice
entendía algo y es mi responsabilidad
contagiar sobre esto el segundo poder
que tiene el feminismo
es el poder de la autodisciplina
la autodisciplina que yo practico tiene
que ver con resistir tres tentaciones la
tentación de la queja
la tentación de ejercer y la justificada
resistir la tentación a la ira
justificada y la tentación de resistir
la tentación de caer en el cinismo
esa es la práctica de la autodisciplina
no quejarse no ser cínica
y no responder de manera iracunda aunque
la ira esté justificada
el feminismo como les digo es una
práctica así que hay que entrenar todos
los días porque resistir la ira a veces
es bien difícil en este país
el tercer poder que tiene el feminismo
es el poder de la audacia
la audacia es un impulso que te conecta
con una valentía ancestral es una
valentía heredada
sin la audacia los cambios no son
posibles
la audacia te recuerda que tú eres una
fuerza de la naturaleza
una fuerza arrolladora
imparable incansable indomable sin la
audacia nada es posible y hay que
practicarla porque nuestro mundo es un
mundo que lo que impulsa es la cobardía
lo que premia es la cobardía
el cuarto poder que le confiere el
feminismo es el poder del efecto
multiplicador de las semillas toda
semilla tiene un poder de latencia
la ten en la tierra dormida y cada
semilla tiene el poder de multiplicarse
en nuevas semillas de los frutos de las
flores de las que nacen de ella así que
el poder del efecto multiplicador del
feminismo recae en que podamos
contagiarnos todos y todas de que esto
es una idea y una práctica que es buena
para todos para todas para niños para
niñas para hombres para mujeres porque
lo que promueve es un mundo donde no
quepa la desigualdad donde ninguna
desigualdad justifica la violencia
el quinto poder que tiene el feminismo
es el poder del entramado el poder del
entramado se relaciona con las redes de
intercambio de saberes y de intercambio
de solidaridad es las redes que tejen la
memoria colectiva que siempre está bajo
amenaza la memoria colectiva siempre
está en peligro de ser capturada en
permanente peligro de ser capturada
cooptada cambiada
con estos cinco poderes yo propongo que
es posible cambiar el mundo y propongo
que la práctica del feminismo es el
camino no estoy diciendo que es un
modelo no estoy diciendo que es una
receta estoy diciendo que es un camino y
que ese camino es el camino del cambio y
que ese cambio es el cambio hacia la
construcción de un mundo que vamos a
construir todos y todas pero el cambio
lo tenemos que impulsar las mujeres lo
vamos a impulsar las mujeres solo las
mujeres
a compañeros
[Aplausos]